foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back to the break room Our
Daily Show that keeps you updated on the
nerdy news you need to know
um today we've got a lot of fun stuff to
talk about including Wonderman news I've
been accidentally in the office calling
him Power Man repeatedly which is
um Powerman 5000 of course uh one of the
preeminent late 90s uh uh all metal
bands
yeah
Rob Zombie's brother it is isn't Power
Man uh Luke Cage isn't that like yeah
uh we're only talking about either of
those things instead we were talking
about Wonder Man and power line of
course is one of the greatest solo
artists in all of these Mickey see you
they could cross over they are
technically all over by the mouse Mickey
had a dog best friend and then owned a
dog
make that make sense to me okay uh 30
seconds in we're off track
um once we're talking about uh Creed 3
News Agatha Covenant of chaos news
there's a lot of kind of casting and
shooting news in the MCU uh that we're
going to talk about and I mean Eric boss
has a video already coming out on the
channel Mephisto confirmed uh with me
here today to confirm Mephisto I've got
koi Erica
uh Tommy McDonald it's crazy we actually
had to deliver what was it 15 crates of
Gatorade to Eric to rehydrate after that
news station what are you saying
dehydrated in Tommy uh uh I'll just say
excitement
that's a rapturous Droid okay all right
he was engorged with joy oh my god let's
put it this way he was basically like uh
you know in the in the Johnny Depp Willy
Wonka when Mike TV's been pressed or not
or when Violet blog rides but stretched
yep that was Eric he was like waffling
around like a wacky you're right the
first time well uh Violet Beauregard got
Juiced that's right Mikey TV got to
express them to make him normal yes yeah
anyways okay
um welcome everybody to the break room
uh first and foremost and we're not
gonna play the entire trailer though
it's a fun trailer we got our first
trailer for Creed Three uh featuring
King himself Jonathan majors in
um the antagonist role opposite of
Michael B Jordan's uh Creed who's also
uh Michael B Jordan also directing yes
no Mike so it does appear unless they're
saving this as a reveal that the rumor
that that Jonathan Majors plays clever
links are a relative in Clover Lane is
false and I'm a little relieved even
though I love the like Poetic everything
is related this universe is like you
know every everyone knows everyone it
would have been a little bit about on
the nose if it's like he only fights
Rocky's enemy yeah yeah it's something a
little too much recent Star Wars films
as well right everybody needs to be
related genetically we're the only
boxers this lineage and this lineage
Apollo or Adonis what's your last name
but the trailer looks great uh both
those actors I mean Michael B Jordan's
always been ripped to the gills and then
all of those films but Jonathan Majors
holy hell of course that Men's Health
special they did I sure did it has been
inspired that's why I'm doing 100 grams
of protein man Jonathan Majors training
I've been off this week I've been doing
two a days like two a days good God I
had pizza twice yesterday
it sounds kind of two a day uh but we're
excited for that film that's been a
really fun franchise and again three
members of the MCU we've got a
killmonger a king and a valkyrie all
heavily featured in that film that's
right
um uh during an interview at the Chicago
Film Festival Catherine Hahn confirmed
that Agatha Covenant of chaos will begin
shooting next month so again a reminder
that shows scheduled to come out winter
of 2023. it's still a little ways out
but um they're gonna start shooting soon
I I mean a show like that you assume has
to have so much it's kind of a medium
level to smaller level effects that it
must take forever because all of the
Witchcraft and Magic requires all the
the purple embellishments yes I hope
they do like a Salem set like I hope
there's a physical set and they go back
to Salem because we teased that with
Wanda and my friend Emma just got
confirmed and she was in one division
she's uh she was one of the people in
science yeah
shout out to him bring her in and she's
coming back for her which is intriguing
to me because she was part of the mind
washing and the modern day New Jersey so
yeah it'll be interesting there's been
some speculation Covenant of chaos is it
going to be you know some kind of
flashback to some time between ancient
Salem and modern day of what Agatha was
doing during that window or it seems
like we have to spend at least some time
in New Jersey it'd be cool if we see
some of the one division events happen
from her perspective because there's so
many times she left right yeah and like
there's so much manipulation that she
had done hence the Agatha all along it'd
be cool if we get kind of a retroactive
flashback because it's gonna be two
years by that point it'd be cool to see
what she was doing and that tie into why
we're invested again yes maybe that's
how she comes into play that could be
really fun also this series could be
like a reverse wand division where she
starts brainwashing eventually and
slowly regains her uh fully that was my
thought is maybe perhaps that your
friend Emma what's your character's name
on the show thank you Daddy perhaps
daddy triggers uh Agatha's memories to
like reminder of who she is or something
well that'd be cool yeah she's trapped
yeah we're really excited for that
series also mainly because yeah we have
no idea what the hell that series is
going to be and that's exciting I just
want to see mad witches doing witchy
things yes yeah what uh real quick and
happy witches as well wait yes what are
the odds we get another musical sequence
in this show I hope it's great a whole
musical episode it does tie into our
Eric Fox News though what if we start to
get the occult bigger like what if you
know as go this Direction with werewolf
by night with potential Mephisto with
all these things what if that's well
befista will hopefully be established in
the MCU by then right sooner rather than
later yeah so maybe he rolls on over to
the Covenant yeah okay we're jumping in
sorry I got excited I don't know I get
excited and by the way if you're excited
we got a hum Dinger of a mandatory fun
today okay I hate to promote these
things but you don't want to stick
around and if you haven't already liked
this video hit the like button now I'm
sick of waiting for you people yeah like
it now and subscribe to our Channel
there's over there's over 1 000 people
watching currently there should be 1 000
likes on this side I ate two pizzas
yesterday and that means I provided
enough fiber for you rats for months and
I left some of the cheese and toppings
in the Box because I knew my trash bags
we want a little
snacks at least you can do is like this
video and Super Chat don't forget to
subscribe yeah thank you to the super
core can Cory Craig and Julian there
Elizabeth City thank you for the other
folks super chatting um after about
three and a half months of shooting
Sydney is confirmed that Sony's Madame
Webb film is wrapped are you big on your
socials uh you know I do not follow her
I browse them just because I want to
know when the movie rats uh that's the
only reason you follow yeah yeah
interesting same here yeah that's it but
that's good we don't have I can
unsubscribe now thank god
um yeah we've seen some said photos of
that you know not a lot of other news
coming out of that other than the the
release was delayed just a little bit
but we know it's wrapped so that that's
good news uh unlike blade uh at least
they get to finish uh principal
photography there so uh we're looking
forward to that film as well I I know uh
there's a lot of rumors around that
movie but if some of them are true I
think that movie could actually be a
Bonafide spumcy hit it sounds like
spumcy spider Sony Pictures Universal
Spider-Man of Marvel and Marvel
characters I think that Sony really does
like invest in The Fan Experience and I
think they listen right so after things
have gone right and wrong I think
they're very invested like in what we
want and if things Direction that's
that's a new age actors I mean Adam
Scott great actor Dakota Johnson Sydney
Sweeney there were more people listed to
us since forgotten a lot of talented
young ladies in that film yeah the the
woman from Scream the recent scream
reboot I believe is in there somewhere
else that black cat movie we were
talking about like that'd be cool
remember there was a silver and black
that we're gonna do that little like Duo
I'm really hoping this does well so we
lead to that person yeah because we know
again uh upcoming Spider-Man spin-off
films we're definitely getting craving
the hunter we're definitely getting
Madam Webb those things are in some
stage of production and then there's
other things that have been talked about
or some early stage of production like
like that and um some other films um oh
and we're also getting El muerto
uh number one music artist worldwide
Morpheus too can't be far right I mean
that's it's in the can right now
um careful sipping those we break one a
week for like sketch whims all of my
sketch pitches are first I break and
Morgan mug and then uh then we do some
sort of comedic idea that's how they're
building they're only getting more rare
comedic ideas uh Natasha Lube or diesel
I believe I hope I'm pronouncing your
name properly Natasha um who's the actor
playing Sabine say okay Tommy Sabine
Sabine thank you uh in the upcoming
Ahsoka series announces she's wrapped so
presumably that series is is production
is what d23 koi tell me if it seemed as
though they were they were the finishing
stages of principal photography yeah she
was just it was seemed like she was busy
filming but they also sounded near Ducks
yeah I imagine it was like Hey we're
about to go to post-production we're
tightening this out and that seems like
a good timeline
and what is what's the next Star Wars
series we're getting is that Mandalorian
season three right and then and then
Ahsoka is the next one after that and
then and or two I believe after that
yeah yes that sounds right so uh again
someday the acolyte
and skeleton skeleton crew a film
yes it's a movie series I'm almost
positive John that's a movie right movie
is it like a movie like a live action
movie uh yeah like a full Harry Styles
confirmed movie
um Harry Styles for skeleton key you
heard it here first I I can't I've spent
the last three to four months of my life
thinking skeleton crew was a TV was your
reality just rocked it is a little bit
wow was especially wild is a simple IMDb
search
changed everything and again a quick
reminder FBI restore my internet service
to my house I'm not on the spice Trail
anymore I'm not importing any drugs or
slugs to my house give me my wi-fi back
give me my wi-fi back
oh the spice Trail uh She-Hulk uh
showrunner Jessica GAO uh did an
interview recently uh after the finale
of that series which you kind of talked
about a potential involvement of the
leader Tim Blake Nelson's character from
The Ed Norton Hulk movie in She-Hulk She
haven't talked about like there's an
early version of the show that kind of
pitched his involvement this is like
multiple years ago in the development of
the series
um she didn't even really remember the
exact context but that she kind of asked
to include him and it kind of didn't
work out but maybe we were speculating
like does that plant the seed in Marvel
HQ of like we should find some reason to
bring that guy back or Jessica gal is
just constantly creating ideas and
they're like yeah not for She-Hulk
because we already have it planned Marty
and steal that idea and repackage it
just enough I mean because we know he's
confirmed for uh Captain America New
World Order yes yeah uh so um Tim Blake
getting in there somehow
um uh other casting news actor Paul
Calderon who you know he's been in the
Amazon series Bosch but I will always
think of him and this is a way way back
in the day he played the bartender in
Pulp Fiction oh yeah when they go to
Marcelo Marcellus Wallace's nightclub
he's the bartender that uh Samuel L
Jackson and John Travolta talk to um but
he's been cast in Iron Heart in a role
as of yet unannounced but there's some
speculation that he's playing the Hood's
Father Anthony Ramos's character
with its Magic Bullets yes does the
father have Magic Bullets or just no yes
yeah or maybe oh he gets his Magic
Bullets from his father okay who knows
coin needs a Magic Bullet to get all his
proteins
I think I'm wondering if if the person
we're going to talk about here in a
second is where he gets magical
good transition so this is uh a somewhat
confirmed still a little ephemeral out
there but a deadline is a pretty
reputable Hollywood publication is
confirming that Tasha bear Cohen will be
playing Mephisto in Iron Heart it's so
amazing uh which is wild that's awesome
casting
um amazing it feels like maybe even
the level that level of actor and
casting denotes that Mephisto will not
be limited to just appearing at all that
might be his first appearance and then
we see him other places be in an episode
of ironheart to give the hood his powers
and then
go away and then not to be heard from
again until a movie yes I imagine this
is a long game and I never would have
expected the the meme of it to get so
big to the point where it would because
Mephisto is not a big deal in the comic
books like you ask a comic book fan like
who they love mephisto's in the top 300
like it's not a character we seek but
with a lot of the popularity of the
story lines they've pulled like they
effectively did one more day in
Spider-Man no way home but they did it
better in my opinion by removing him but
everyone is expecting it at such a level
I'm wondering if this is one of the
biggest occasions of Marvel being like
hey the fans demanded it Mephisto yeah
and then you get someone of this caliber
so therefore it's it's earned it's not a
Cheesy thing like you got to make
Mephisto interesting which is no small
feat like it's a very not well written
character most of the time so I'm really
curious where he goes yeah and he's like
pretty ridiculous right like basically
the devil
um which is pretty wild but like this
series with like the hood being
Supernatural and maybe where we've been
talking about kind of Marvel has
increasingly opened the door into the
supernatural realm of Marvel with
werewolf by Knight and totally great
like I I really would argue World finite
is one of the best ways to go so far
left because if you look at everything
Marvel is it's been very grounded for
three phases as much as superhero
properties can be and then phase four
they're like what if we flipped table
and now Mephisto doesn't feel far off
that's pretty fast if you think about it
guys I don't want to interrupt the chat
is heavily reporting that I may be
correct and skeletal might be a series
no John can we IMDb that
yeah can you IMDb that Jessica she's not
paying attention
um
Jessica's in the oven the Hunt is on
can't appear on oh all right well and
quite I love that that's it
kind of World by night kind of showing
us different ways that that um uh Marvel
can go with tone like I've kind of been
assuming ironheart will be a relatively
grounded Series right a character
building uh a tech super suit that's all
the Iron Man films that's super grounded
there's no superpowers or anything
involved but like this seems to be
hinting it maybe the show's not like
have you seen the trailer I have not
okay so about a fourth of the trailer
deals with the motivations of the hood
so a large chunk of the trailer was like
hey you're falling into the wrong crowd
this guy the hood blah blah and that's
why I love the trailer because that's
not a character again much like Mephisto
nobody wants the hood like it's not a
character we saw it but with the way
he's playing him with the story they're
going going with it does look like
there'll be a supernatural element to
this show that doesn't necessarily have
one in the comic books so I can see
there being an entire occult element
leading into blade leading into
potentially doing stuff with Moon Knight
we've talked about Ghost Rider a lot
that could be a thing Donnie Blaze was
clearly a mislead I think we're getting
phase five might be more Supernatural
and devilish than we would have assumed
yeah in this particular series and again
Ryan coogler producing it like you don't
associate the Black Panther films are
pretty grounded I mean there's some like
uh uh ancestral plane stuff there in a
little bit but like yeah anyways I'm
very excited when the trailer is
officially released and we get a little
bit more idea about what the tone of
this entire series it's gonna be really
interesting remember my rant I Miss
Marvel when I was saying like it's
really interesting we're getting this
many different versions of the afterlife
we've got the field of reads we've got
the the veil we've got you know what um
Valkyrie deals with we've got all of
these different afterlives what would be
really interesting to me is to see how
Mephisto fits in a world where there's
different Hells different Heavens
different like other worlds especially
as we're going to see your what if these
are all different Realms what if these
are all different planes what if that
ties into the Multiverse so when we get
to secret Wards what if Dead characters
can come back by way of Mephisto what if
Mephisto is how we get Tony Stark or
Steve Rogers back oh my
God instead of not believing Peter
Parker Spider-Man what if we bring back
characters from the dead with deals with
the devil sash bar and Cohen oh and
Tommy's been sitting here patiently
waiting now either we're gonna eat crowd
or you're going to uh Force us to what's
the answer Tommy listen you know I'm a
man of integrity you know I'm a man
who's willing to admit when I'm wrong
however you know I have no problem
apologizing on this show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I stand corrected
um so wait so we know we were talking
earlier about mandalory's Mandalorian
season three is the next Star Wars
series followed by Ahsoka followed by
Skeleton Crew probably before and or two
Skeleton Crew is that a movie it's a TV
do you think they'll go quarterly like
Marvel
oh good question well in this year we
only got this year we got three Star
Wars series five Marvel so more than
quarterly yeah so maybe and it feels
like they're ramping up they're doing a
little bit more Star Wars series next
year
um because there's hey there's uh
acolyte there's something to be done
with Boba Fett Etc
um okay more on that later John muted me
which is censorship
you're not sent to the voice of the
people we will not be said search
blaming blaming John but there might
just be a microphone tonight a fire has
risen on the break room a couple a
couple last words on on social
um he was supposedly he's been spotted
at Marvel facilities at UK's Pinewood
Studios which makes it cut makes a lot
of sense in that he's from England so
like maybe maybe that was swayed him to
participate in the project a little bit
you mean I could just go down the street
and film this and not have to fly to
Atlanta or something like that that's
cool
um and and again yeah is there potential
he's in Covenant of chaos
and that'd be a cool way to give the
origins of Witchcraft the vehicle way to
bring him further into the MCU uh again
this actor is so good and people mainly
know him for prank stuff but the talent
you have to have to stay in a bit like
that and like when he is an actor he's
always incredible so I you don't cast
him for a one-off I I have to imagine
this is for the Four Seasons probably a
10-year contract and it could be a such
a similar situation as David Tennant
playing the program man and Jessica
Jones he could be that kind of like
mischievous villainous character yeah
they have similar energy I like that
yeah yeah kind of charming kind of funny
but also very easily I don't know why I
rooted for the purple man the entire
time in Jessica Jones yeah
that's bad I thought he was the
protagonist Jessica come uh wield your
uh she's got headphones on she's not
having a good job maybe people can't
even hear me because of our megalomaniac
producer
don't worry Simon we can hear you okay
uh transitioning here to some other
quasi-confirmed casting
um supposedly yayama Abdul Mateen the
second uh of uh Watchman Fame uh Aquaman
Fame we were joking he's in all the Man
movie Candyman Candyman he is the man
he's the man in all the mans
um is in talks to play or some stage of
negotiation to beat Marvel's Wonder Man
um
screen geek is reporting to rumors
because he showed up on like there's
like a casting sheet that had him on it
Tommy's gonna break his fingers
so anyways now this wonder man has like
his dead names popped up before we've
talked about it a little bit but maybe
uh some some of our viewers may not know
because he hasn't appeared in any MCU
stuff Coy can you give us a little bit
of background on Wonder Man slash Simon
Williams so his power is really
interesting because he has like ionic
manipulation so he's very powerful but
it's really the writer determines what
his powers are because when you say
those you put those words together and
it's just freedom but uh what I like
about him is that he started as a
villain kind of became a hero but his
arrogance puts him on that not not quite
anti-hero side he still does good
choices but he usually butts heads with
people right he's usually got a little
bit of a chip in his shoulder usually
thinks he's better than other people but
I like his hawkeye-esque origin where he
started as a bad guy realize the ear in
his ways but kept a little bit of a like
and I think that'd be really great for
Yaya Abdul betin the second because
we've seen him steal a lot of scenes of
black panther we were supposed to get
that spin-off movie with him basically
leading the darker the deeper whatever
or the trench yes yeah yeah there was
supposed to be the trench movie that was
going to be a Black Adam sorry are a
black man's a sequel effectively and
we've seen him do incredible work in the
Watchmen like the actor himself does
great work all the time I'd love to see
him get to play something long form and
duplicitous I would rather see him do
this than something just straight up
hero or straight up villain as we've
seen so far because the Nuance there be
incredible and the character himself
deals with a lot of different elements
of Kang which is interesting so Kang
kind of revives him from like a deep
sleep depth depending on the continuity
and manipulates into into helping him so
he was a bit of a Kang Lackey for a time
which is how I think they're going to
incorporate him here is if we're going
into this Kang era I imagine those are
storylines are going to pull from is the
Wonder Man Kang Dynamic and that ship in
the shoulder because we've had a lot of
Heroes and a lot of villains but we
haven't had a lot of Punisher types or
or you know arrogant people since Tony
Stark he could be kind of the Tony Stark
with that like bravado as a hero which
we don't really have and there is like a
lot of backstory in the comics and it
can vary a little bit right like uh one
that we think they're gonna run with is
he has a background as a Hollywood stunt
man yes get into why we think that might
be the version they're they're using
well the shield give it all the pop
culture awareness yes and uh there are
also some other versions of his
backstory where like he kind of came
from wealth like he inherited a weapons
Factory from his family and stuff like
that so we don't know exactly how much
of that they're going to use I mean it's
a character that's been around the
comics a long time so there's a lot that
they could pick and choose from but the
reason we think they might be running
with the Hollywood angle of him being
maybe an actor or a participant in in
Hollywood is a couple reasons a that
supposedly the working title is call
back which is Tommy knows what is what
does a callback mean uh the Skeleton
Crew is an upcoming California
called something
[Applause]
get called back to audition again like a
second round book the job but you are
now uh in a smaller group of uh people
under consideration AKA known as the
bechtold that's right you show up at a
call back and Tommy's in the room just
leave okay he's booking it or I just
farted real bad okay that's how I would
Ace my callback but everybody Dukes
other stuff we know about the series is
um it has been previously announced that
um Trevor Slattery himself Ben Kingsley
sir Ben Kingsley is going to appear in
the series
um and like a connection there the
executive producer of this is Daniel
Destin Creighton
Dustin Daniel Craig okay he has three
names that I am constantly mixing which
up uh but uh he's producing this and he
directed Shang Chi he's also directing
Kang Dynasty
um but maybe you know he's pulling some
characters from Shang Chi we know Trevor
Slattery is going to show up who else
might show up we don't know we've been
speculating around the office about like
who are the other like actors or
Hollywood types that already exist in
the MCU we've got uh Evan Peters yeah
referenced 100 times Bingo and I really
think like the the actor awareness of it
all is going to come into play because
that is a big part of what he represents
in the show and him and shield have a
lot of like back and forth and that that
pop culture again awareness I think is
going to be they're calling it callback
and we've had moments where I think in
Guardians of the Galaxy 2 either one or
two Nathan filliam is going to play him
and I think that there's been very few
times James Gunn's been told no or
hasn't worked out it might be because
they wanted him for something bigger
they want them long term and then in one
division in the background of some of
the interviews there was a Wonder Man
poster and a lot of people were
speculating One Division was going to
have him because she was in a TV show so
there was a lot of you know
mephisto-esque so maybe that was just
literally either taunting us because
they've been trolling us this whole
phase four or it was actually in
development that long ago and we've just
now gotten to it but either way Yaya is
perfect for this dude yeah we also have
the entire Asgardian theater troop yes
yeah yeah yeah
them show up to audition for something
but still be like asgardians so they're
like they're not real good Melissa
McCarthy in Hollywood trying to be
actors yeah yeah well we know they're
living in the United States right now
right as per 11 Thunder
um and yeah some other information
that's going to come out uh variety uh
reported that they'd heard that it was
going to be a Hollywood satire
um but that's not 100 confirmed the tone
of it um a writer has been hired Andrew
guest who's worked on community 30 Rock
Brooklyn Nine-Nine uh also worked on
Hawkeye I believe so it's like it's a
pretty comedic uh background so it feels
like yeah like koi was saying about
She-Hulk maybe this is going for a
similar tone it's ironic Yaya has not
done much comedy work he's almost
entirely dramatic uh actor but I've
interviewed him a few times in like off
camera wicked funny I'd actually love to
see him get to flex that because there's
he's done so much drama he's done horror
drama Sci-Fi Action I'd love to see that
side of him I've already been What
attracted him too well uh I do love that
he was recently quoted and I think it
was a little taken out of context but
when talking about Aquaman and his role
in that he called it clown work yeah uh
now I think he was like maybe literally
referring I think the study of clown
that is like a theater principle but it
was taken as like oh this guy does not
like appearing in superheroes uh but of
course that that was not the case and he
is excited about doing this now one
thing we were just speculating in the
office this uh project which has been
talked about and we've known it was in
the works for quite a while but it's not
slated we do not have a release date or
even a year
um now some of that could be we have
nothing uh slated no Disney plus series
trees slated for phase six so kind of
2025 in that era late 2024 into 2025 but
also what's the potential this is not a
series what's the potential this is a
special presentation along the lines of
werewolf by night or something like that
and because those things were not
necessarily on a lot of the release
calendars beforehand they just kind of
are dropping those I would love to start
using those as like either plan Pilots
or backdoor Pilots either you know you
just have things come out you're like do
we like this character do we think that
the audience responds then green lighted
or you do hour-long specials as a way to
do Origins leading up to them in the
movies leading up to like how great
would it be to see the X-Men get five
individual specials leading up to their
movies we actually get time to invest in
the storm actually I'm like almost like
beefed up Marvel one shot exactly yes
because they do that in events all the
time you give like oh I don't know this
character is here's their one shot here
so if they're if they're backstories
maybe Marvel back shots
I think that's Marvel after Dark
that's the Black Label uh
Marvel Max back shots hold for Tommy old
for Tommy uh okay great well and Corey
already kind of mentioned this but the
potential here again the presence of uh
Dustin Daniel [ __ ] who's going to be
directing King Dynasty and it's like he
has an overall uh producer John was
mentioning he has an overall deal at
Marvel right so he could have probably
pitched a lot of things there's a reason
he pitched this and there's a reason
they said yes to this now as a part of a
bigger picture maybe he just likes this
character and he wanted to work uh with
Wonder Man or he wanted to set up
something that's gonna appear in in King
Dynasty we don't know if we're getting
Ashanti 2 or when that might happen uh
maybe
Dynasty Will kind of effectively be like
that or we don't know he might show up
in a team-up movie but West Coast
Avengers are are I think coming and he's
a foundational member like wonder man is
huge for West Coast Avengers I can
totally see this I could see uh Wonder
Man She-Hulk Kate Bishop that kind of
element if she doesn't have the Young
Avengers I could see us having a hell of
Avengers teams coming up
uh sorry to if this is derailing a
little bit has Jack Russell been
confirmed for any more upcoming projects
in Marvel or like did they say I mean it
feels like with the man thing the
success of that like that that's he's
coming they're working on it but no
nothing nothing's been confirmed I mean
I think they could do a werewolf fight
producer John I just shouted uh Jack
Russell's in the skeleton not on Mike
doesn't uh it's not a movie John
um well or I mean hey poor Oscar Isaac
can't even get a confirmed Moon night
season too so I mean they're not gonna
Rush uh confirm uh second appearance of
werewolf by now he's like I'll let out a
few things but I still got my secrets
and I love well and it also it makes me
wonder right like the the Mephisto
casting the Wonder Man casting these are
kind of unofficial because you know
feige wants the official to be him out
on stage in front of a bunch of people
cheers yeah they want to use their uh
some kind of a big platform right to get
a lot of attention the brand new black
hat on with some new logos oh I love
those hats
um uh great uh Thomas yeah
uh Tammy you mentioned derailing earlier
uh you know what derails the show more
often than anything else
you're not wait no noises coming out
don't we oh I think producer John may
have uh censored him again in real life
though yeah he's doing this he's doing
the fake sliding glass door bit
um
it's a segment I'm doing under duress so
play the graphic like it's the best pick
my graphic again
yes the segment
not of men or mice so we play the
graphic Thrice into the game
the segment more important than God so
we play this graphic quad hit it again
all right
whether it's Trevor Slattery Kingo the
Asgardian thespians or wonder cheapers
creepers can we get one ounce of
professionals nobody can hear this but
us I can hear it and I have to go on
I'm not kidding all right don't want
this to go viral I'm just joking uh what
the Trevor's Trevor Slattery the
Asgardian thespians Wonder Man or Kingo
actors are having what I like to call a
Marvel moment
I want to give all our hosts a chance to
audition for their own characters
however I have made this into a little
twisted game like jigsaw from the Saw
movies I am going to give you guys
audition sides but I'm not telling you
what Marvel character you're auditioning
for now these scripts are littered with
Clues as to who your character is
if you know
you may stop your audition and declare
who you think your character is and if
you are correct
you will win the role now unfortunately
I cannot be here oh no tell me but
you're here right now well I know I have
to go uh my doctor Dr nasty has located
a uh
um llama testicle as it was established
Canon yesterday I am ball deficient not
too far from the eel stomach yeah the
eel stomach is connected to the Llama
testicle llama testicles connected to
the Moose anus so anyway uh anyhow uh Dr
nasty is going to be putting that law
metastinal in uh also you know this is a
movie you got to start scheduling your
medical appointments outside of the
three to four pm I wish I had uh I I
also obviously my everyone knows my my
cousin T Michael bechtold is uh go back
to the studio uh he is currently
producing several projects oh wow uh but
he couldn't be here no
so who's gonna run this segment dummy
I've got someone coming in today that I
think you guys are gonna love please uh
do some Euro you know actors do some
actor warm-ups okay I'll do some vocal
exercises by calling out the Super Chat
thank you to everybody who's been
sending in super chat today dark rift
thank you can of cheese I love your
username can of cheese great I love the
parts where we could hear him uh I think
it's calling out of Tommy's uh uh fake
use of uh um volume uh Corey can't
really uh you can't silence silence him
like that it's like saying water isn't
wet that's that's true we've tried many
ways to silence Tommy and it's never
worked
um tales of the Jedi is next it's yet
another kind of sometimes mentioned Star
Wars series yeah yeah I think it seems
like it in maybe a further state of
development hey bros how you doing whoa
bro how we doing everybody what's going
on how's everybody social presence
everybody Graham and everybody talking
how you doing my name is nft Michael
bechtold uh
I'm Tommy's nephew uh I am also T
Michael's son what does nft stand for uh
not [ __ ] today folks and that is
meant as a uh as a verb I'm not [ __ ]
today all right I've been in what's
known as a trash bag
uh anyway my dad runs P Michael Bento
Productions I'm nft Michael Bechtel uh
and I am gonna have you guys audition
for me today can I get y'all to clear
out and come in one at a time everybody
clear out of my audition room please all
right okay which order should we come in
I'll call you in when I watch it okay
okay all right thanks nft I'm looking
for a Zach Huddleston yeah that's me is
that Carlson how you doing Zach good do
you need me to slay I do yeah look
straight into camera four slate your
name height weight sexual orientation
blood type are you willing to be an
organ donor have you ever donated in
Oregon before will you do nudity will
you do full pen
and are you vaccinated it and if you're
vaccinated you can just get out okay uh
Zach Huddleston uh uh recently booked uh
not recently it was four years ago I
booked a regional commercial for
Hospital change nice absolutely that
sounds great all right here you go
I'll be reading the role of Tommy okay
and again as soon as I think I know who
this role is I should announce that I
mean that's the premise of the game yeah
uh for the cameras you know maybe let it
ride a couple laptop kicks thumbs up we
won't be looking at the chat as soon as
you think you know who it is throw that
in the chat okay all right my bro ham
okay nah let me get my reading voice on
been a while since I pounded the boards
but it ain't been that long since I
patted the brought it's been so long the
smell is so dry all right have a seat
done you need to hear this huh just
because I walk with a limp doesn't need
to meet doesn't mean I need to say let's
start that over you plug the line a
little bit take it from the top hey
don't be nervous man it's just me and
dash daddy behind the cam you may
recognize him from his award-winning
porn series Romancing the boners all
right
I have a seat down you need to hear this
hey
just because I walk with a limp doesn't
mean I need to sit all the time uh fine
let your pride be your downfall you
proud little peppy Pat let's let's cut
the BS we all know you're pretending I
don't know what you're talking about the
serpent oh sorry those are yours I did
your life get back out and we'll try
this again okay I got nervous then guys
something about your eyes makes me feel
like you've killed before and what's
your bare hands take your seat down you
need to hear this
just because I walk with a limp doesn't
mean I need to sit all the time fine let
Pride be your downfall let's cut the BS
we all know you're pretending I don't
know what you're talking about these
serpent bite scars are from spring break
I understand that remembering the past
can be difficult you've lost a lot of
family members but now your people need
you my classmates need me my girlfriend
needs me I'm close to some medical
breakthroughs none of that matters that
the end of the world comes don't you
have another name for that the end of
the world
I honestly have no idea what you were
talking about did my friend and frequent
teammate Tony Stark put you up to this
Donald Blake you are not who you say you
are now tell me your real name
Donald Blake AKA
the lizard Thor the answer is my office
get out of my office all this serpent
[ __ ] threw me off okay he got bit by a
servant yes okay done you'll never work
in this town again uh
all right
[Music]
Andrew
all right Stewie how are you I'm doing
all right I'm too close not too close I
just had surgery all right
I'm gonna slate uh yeah go ahead and
slate your name slate your thing that
you're most afraid of in the world slate
your favorite color and any allergies to
medications you might have uh koi John
Dro I'm this tall this much weight I
look like this I feared death
don't we all but it's coming for
everyone but you know who's not coming
for everyone me my spell is so dry
well well well Rod my man it's been too
long what do you want well for one I
want to know where you got those jeans
you have incredible taste flattery will
get you nowhere listen I need your help
your twin brother Daniel has gone
missing and we think the rose might have
something to do with it I believe it's a
fist to start family drama look I don't
have time for this all right I'm out
recruiting a new family my own perhaps
you know a nation of sorts that's a bit
dramatic but then again you are a former
fashion designer who lost his Empire
because of Ruthless business practice I
can show you ruthless the same way I
showed Spider-Man careful Roderick we
can and will take that costume and gear
back from you if we think you're going
too far am i some sort of hobgoblin you
got the part yeah yes
next uh oh wow uh my assistant
just told me we have a draw we have a
walk-in oh no uh there's a there's a
certain auditioner that was not on the
list Jessica Clements hey we've been
here for four
daughter she's in Hollywood
he's Roger Clemens daughter here are
your sides slate towards the camera
state your name the next time you're
available for a full steak dinner and
whether you'd like to be picked up or
Uber and if you're willing to split the
check
I'm Jessica Clemens six foot two and no
[Laughter]
well you've got a lot of guts coming in
here Cassie I knew you were gonna say
that there's a seat to your left about
four feet from the ground I know he's
jumped my line going we're starting I
don't think there's there's a space here
though I said take it take a deep breath
what
are you are you reading the same thing I
don't think I am
yeah you are
she got the part well you got a lot of
guts coming in here Cassie
I knew you were going to say that
there's a seat to your left about four
feet from the ground I know
you really caused a mess giving Jessica
Jones all that information she's on a
rampage now I only provide people with
the clarity they need to be productive
so much arrogance is that because you
have an awesome New York City apartment
with a great view of the Hudson river
which is ironic look what do you want
you want me to fix your mind or perhaps
fix someone else's mind stay out of my
mind
and also stay out of Peter Parker's mind
Cassandra
please call me
guest name killmonger
you're fired you'll never work in this
town again
oh all right
is there anyone else left in the room
can anyone else read Erica wushu yeah
hello Eric hey welcome to tnst Michael
bechtold Studios all right we're gonna
have you read today can you slate into
the camera your name uh the last time
that you felt like you might pee your
pants a little bit uh your favorite
candy your least favorite candy an
animal that makes you happy and an
animal that you feel like you might be
attracted to if you were the same
species of animal okay all right uh
Erica lusu six foot two that's not just
my Tinder height that's my real life
hike and uh animal I fear or could be
attracted to uh a tall Basset Hound oh
wow
it's got to be tall but once it's part
nft all right I gotta say that answer
really shook me to my core you know it's
not shaking my bed because I made a dry
spell look this case is open and shut
you killed your brother over a piece of
pie it was an accident I swear please
don't send me back to my father oh we
found his body too you've been busy he
kept me chained in the basement and he
pulled out my teeth to torture me let me
guess your mother deserved to die as
well no I only pretended to kill her
she actually lived comfortably before
she was diagnosed with cancer and then
killed by a member of the red right hand
I guess I'll buy that story
but what about your brother your sister
Clara says you're pretty rough on him my
brother was murdered by a Canadian
sociopath eh
Victor before we lock you up and throw
away the key I want you to meet my
friend
Magneto
I think you two would have a lot to talk
about
this is
Red Hulk get out of here it's saber
tooth
I got cats
[Applause]
where do I tell my dad that we couldn't
even cast two actors in this project one
thing I'll say about this this this
studio this channel is this is dry of
talent as I am of action because God I'm
in a dry spell that's rude uh and if nft
Beck told everybody
all the characters I know all the
characters except the one I was reading
thanks uh dark raft Mikey cheers uh
everybody in the Super Chat we
appreciate you oh Tommy you're back oh
oh God I have a bag of frozen peas on my
Jack Johnson's right now oh let me tell
you the one thing they don't tell you is
that llamas are home along with a couple
of coconuts
anyways testicles as well I guess yeah
wow funny that they'd pick that as a
yeah they're no mule well let's just put
it this way right now uh you know what
math class when they're trying to teach
you about diameters and they have one
giant Circle and then really one tiny
Circle and they show you how many times
the tiny Circle could fit in the giant
Circle yeah that's what my ball sack
looks like right now
got too many circles man and then you
lost me a couple times I throw it in the
chat well obviously was the one who
succeeded in getting the part but also I
was throwing the chat who's read of
their script I liked uh the emphasis
Eric was putting on the syllables thank
you thank you my uncle or my cousin T
Michael Bechtel called me and said that
my nephew nft Michael bechtold had a
great time he thought everyone did a
great job but he was pretty upset in the
car
a lot at it yeah oh it's just because
he's going through a dry spell right now
him too yeah we heard yeah and nft
Michael Beck told uh certainly
non-fungible
um all right thank you all so much for
watching with us today a couple things
to tease coming up Friday we're doing a
hot ones yes we are ripping off a much
more successful YouTube Enterprise so
far
so far they're more successful they have
a head start on the break there's no
reason that the break room can't
overwhelm uh the hot ones in their
billions my sources are saying we will
have eclipsed hot ones
by sometime in March what of what year
second quarter 2023. yes all right after
the guy who hosting yeah
and the Viola Davis might kill him
because she asked in the middle of hers
nobody's whooped your ass yet but these
fat ass oh my God
I've just seen that off the bone clip
500 times like good for her
so we'll be doing that on Friday so tune
in to watch uh some people get very
sweaty uh probably while consuming food
um also we'll be talking about Black
Adam Friday a little bit a spoiler-free
discussion and then Monday maybe we'll
get into it a little bit deeper
um we've got uh the finale of house the
dragon next week Shield's already done
indoor ramping up to a big finale he's
been a great Wookie leaks today check
that out watch me and Eric Voss talking
Wars talking Stars two [ __ ] doors
Talking Hands okay uh two quick things
about Android We're not gonna do a full
segment on it but a we were just we were
speculating in the office you know the
Groundswell of popularity has been slow
for that series even though we think
that show is great we were wondering if
now that she looks done House of dragons
about to wrap up rings the powers done
people might have a little bit more
watch time available uh they've all
binged Dahmer already or whatever right
maybe now is the time a lot of people
discover Andor they've got they've got a
bunch of good episodes they can binge
through and the finale's coming up if
you haven't gotten on the indoor train
yet to get on there you know yeah if
you're significant other is like honey
maybe we could catch up on a new season
of Real Housewives you can go and or and
then never finish the sentence and just
put and or on and you're not being
intellectually dishonest okay
um just publish a thing today about the
volume stages these like giant LED uh
um uh sets that are really popular first
popularized around the Mandalorian and
then a lot of fancy shows and movies are
using these and how like Andor did not
use it at all and kind of like you can
really see it feels like it's a tactile
show they built all practical sets it
has a different feel from book of Boba
Fett or Obi-Wan or some of those I
really hope it does well because I think
we need more of that right like Star
Wars I loved Rogue one because it felt
like the worst part of Star Wars not not
just the Space Opera and I think the
only way to keep it going just like a
Marvel you need to diversify what the
content is as well as the characters
like you need your Space Opera your
Espionage Thriller your Heist Star Wars
is largely Star Wars I think Andor is
the first departure to the scale I think
probably the next big opportunity would
be the Disney plus TV show Skeleton Crew
That's a callback
the other one was a callback also yes
have a good night everybody
[Music]